what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to start doing sir getting in the
habit i guess of doing like video blogs
you know it's kind of like talking to
you guys because i like the idea of just
just talking to you guys like there's no
format no rio like structure to this you
know it's just kind of like whatever I
mean I've got I'm not using my setup so
my audio probably will be nearly as good
it might be kind of lame but whatever
it's really not designed to be as as
like regimented and official as my
marvel explain videos it's just a chance
to kind of chill and talk to you guys
because I think there's something to be
said about youtubers that just sit and
just talk directly with their fans you
know as opposed to you know kind of
providing that's really strict and
regimented to set up where it feels like
you know every video was like a business
meeting or something like that you know
I don't really I don't really like that
kind of feeling but you know one of the
more common questions I guess that I get
from you guys is um you know how did I
get started in this whole YouTube thing
you know what led me to start this whole
this whole Marvel explain thing you know
one of all the things that I could have
talked about why did I choose to talk
about Marvel and its really kind of
funny because nine times outta ten you
guys quantify that we say well I don't
mean to say you shouldn't talk about
Marvel are just curious as to why but I
figured I'd answer that question you
know and and they keep in mind i might
digress a little bit and kind of go off
on tangents but just bear with me but um
I wasn't always doing Marvel Comics oh
yeah i did call duty commentating for a
little while and you know in truth i
wasn't really satisfied with call of
duty commentating I wasn't really i'm
literally happy with it you know in
terms other direction that i was going
in just because you know with the call
duty community you know it was it had
long since established itself by the
time that i joined up you know it just
it has long stints really kind of I
guess movie made its bones and there
were there was a standard by which you
really kind of had to follow if he
wanted to grow and even then you know to
me call of duty it was just such a
simplistic game with such you know
really kind of a boring game after a
while that is hidden care before it you
know I mean going into black ops 1 and
you know breaking 60 kills in TDM you
know how fun is I get after a while now
going into domination you know and
consistently 40-plus kills and less than
10 deaths it's just it got boring to me
you know
and I even with the friends at I played
with you know I mean I could hear their
voices that is you know it was like you
guys want to play call of duty and
they're like all right you know but um
it was just one of those things you know
but but when I had had joined the
YouTube called the community of course
you know i did like anybody else does I
had looked at major commentators at the
time you know of course you had a lot of
commentators in the YouTube community
when it came to college I guys like
Whitney's gamertag and wednes Redemption
you know but the the favor commentator
the number one commentator that I really
could say that I enjoyed the most was
hutch and and hutch was really kind of a
he was a great commentator and I think
he might still do khabar bede from time
to time but I think it's mostly just
kind of various games because he along
with most everybody else has been
playing for a long time got burned out
but you know he really seemed to have a
more organic channel in the sense that
you know the way that he talked I guess
or maybe just kind of the way that he
ran his channel it just seemed more like
you're getting an accurate
representation of him as a person on his
youtube channel as opposed to you know
some fake version for lack of a better
word that I don't mean to yeah I don't
know if you guys understand what I'm
saying when I say that I don't love that
makes any sense but you know I don't
mean to say that there are commentators
that were intentionally putting on a
show but for a lot of people that's
really kind of what you had to do you
know you kind of had to give the people
what they wanted you know in the way
they wanted it in order to to grow and I
didn't like that you know the one thing
that I hate most in the world is being
told what to do and I think that really
kind of follows track with a lot of
people I'm drinking some crystal light I
don't know why that's funny but it is
but anyway you know I I just you know as
soon as I saw as his community is a
comedy channel you know I immediately
latched onto it i mean i was like BAM
you know now it's part of it and you
know he took off for a while or
something like that but you know I i
loved the kind of freedom they came with
really kind of doing your own thing and
really kind of making your own decisions
on what you do and you know ultimately
you know I found that that colony just
became to satisfy the whole comedy
community to me became dis fonda
satisfying ultimately I left but I never
left touches channel i always say
subscribe to his channel
subscribe to his channel for coming up
on like three years or something like
that but you know I was always a big fan
of it but its hype addressed you know I
really kind of wanted a really kind of
wanted like then not necessarily the
lifestyle that that you know youtubers
have going but the kind of freedom that
they have going you know and so I took
off like two weeks from work and I sat
down and I really kind of had asked
myself you know where am I going because
that was the whole purpose of taking off
two weeks that was a whole reason why I
took off from work you know where am I
going in life and what do I want to do
and what I found is previously you know
I had jumped into endeavors where
ultimately you know my goal was to kind
of change my lot in life so to speak but
I didn't really have any passion for it
you know I mean I had enrolled in
college my intention was to go to
medical school but I didn't you know it
sucked College was not the the slightest
bit intellectually challenging to me I
mean I was sitting there in the calculus
class and I was like this is mundane and
boring you know I was sitting in in like
organic chemistry this is mundane and
boring you know it was you know I had a
gender studies course which was awesome
because it made for some lively debate
on a lot of different different subjects
but the book work and the essays and all
I kind of stuff you know the thesis and
any whatnot I hated that you know I
hated that kind of thing so ultimately I
just dropped out of college just you
know just cut it loose and let it go and
you know kept on on keeping on but you
know when I took off these two weeks my
question was what i want to do with the
rest of my life I'm 30 years old or at
least at the time you know I was coming
up on three and I was like you know my
job isn't bad you know but it's just it
doesn't allow my creative juices to flow
and it seems like there were other
things that I could do with my life
besides this so you know during this two
week time period you know I said okay
you know let's make a video about marvel
comics because one of the things that
I'd heard so often in my life was that I
should teach that should be a teacher a
history teacher because I always loved
history history is one of my favorite
things and we were like you should you
should be a teacher you should like to
teach kids about history or teach them
of that math teach something but just
teach because you're so good at teaching
people things and you know I kind of
combine that with my love of comic books
I can I took this idea you know of
teaching people things something that I
love to
to teach people stuff and I said okay
let's combine it with something that I
have a love for that I have a passion
for and then I've always had a passion
for and so I uploaded a video about
jason wyngarde you can still see it i'm
sure a lot of you guys have I think it's
got like a thousand years or something
like that so far but upload of the very
first video that I uploaded about jason
wyngarde and from there it really just
kind of became this thing where i was
just in love with what i was doing you
know i love this element of teaching
people about comic book characters
because i always felt like you know I i
had read all these college you have got
170 something gigabytes of comics in my
hard drive so i've got all this
information but i think that people who
didn't read comics people who are not
really of you know able to read comics
you know the soccer moms are the hockey
dads who are getting off work at five
o'clock and then taking their kids to
practice at six o'clock and then coming
home and having dinner at seven o'clock
you know they don't have time this is
that a read comics but i think that a
lot of people really kind of have maybe
this nostalgia of sorts i'm not really
sure that's so it were like you know
they they always imagined what these
characters were like in the comics you
know and i think nostalgia is really
kind of a good word because i think that
you know they never read comics but they
were always kind of longing for seeing
these characters because i think there
were a lot of people when they looked at
wolverine on the silver screen when they
looked at magneto on a silver screen
when they were in the theaters you know
they really kind of had this desire to
learn about them in the comic book you
know how similar to where they're in the
comic books i think that a lot of people
kind of have this feeling like they were
left out on this great big huge world
they don't know how to get back into it
they don't know how to get into this
world of comic books they don't know how
to get into this world of magneto and
and Professor Charles Xavier you know on
Doctor Strange and even some of the
characters who weren't nearly as popular
in the early runs but became popular
later on you know Luke Cage and the New
Avengers and and stuff like that you
know so ultimately you know I felt like
you know it wasn't necessarily my duty
to enlighten people regarding comic
books but I wanted to kind of you know
teach people about these things because
one of the things that drives me the
guides me so crazy is I think that when
people are talking to other people about
comic books they have this tendency to
really kind of be like asinine about it
you know like wall how could you not
know without such and such a MOBA comics
you know as there was some kind of
travesty or they have somehow failed in
life because they don't know about some
kind of a character in comic books you
mean that's kind of stupid that's kind
of ridiculous yeah I mean you know how
would I feel if I were talking to some
kind of architect and he's talking down
to me because I don't know you know as
much about calculus as he does I mean
you know it's not something I ever took
the time to study it's not ever sending
I've wanted to study I'll just mildly
curious um the subject I just want to
learn about this one aspect of
architecture I'm going to learn
everything about architecture and you
know I really kind of I want to do these
videos in a way where it applied that
kind of desire we're going to apply that
desire to where I could tell people
about characters but I wasn't coming
across preachy I wasn't coming across
you know with this kind of attitude like
you should know about these characters
and if you don't and you clearly screwed
up your life you know I didn't want to
come across that way and so you know I
always tried to try the word them in a
way to where it made sense to where
people could sit down and virtually
anybody could watch one of my videos and
then when they're done you know be a
reasonably I guess aware person about
these characters not necessarily an
expert you know but just be able to hold
their own in a conversation so you know
if there if some 15 year old kid you
know doesn't know who I don't know
doesn't know who that osas you know he
can sit down you know and and watch them
my videos and then go see you know the
Avengers got here or i guess the
avengers to read be guardians of the
galaxy and be waiting in line and know
what people are talking about when
they're talking about Thanos and Adam
warlock and stuff like that you know so
you know it was always something kind of
a desire for me to really kind of create
you know these videos in a way that
people understood and that people could
relate to them without coming across as
kind of a jerk when I made them and so
it's time progressed with all these
videos you know it really kind of became
interesting because people kept
requesting more stuff people get asked
me for more stuff look at saying you
know can you explain this a little more
can you explain that a little more and
ultimately it turn into like these 25
minute long video you know about
Deadpool and stuff like that you know
but there's never really been an insta
where I've just been where I just felt
like God I really don't want to do this
the only time I've ever really felt that
way is when I'm getting off like a 12 or
16 hour shift and I'm mentally exhausted
and I just I know that I have to make a
video because it's got to be out on
monday and i haven't had a chance to
work on it you know that's really the
only time that I ever you know get that
feeling but for me you know if I could
be honest with you guys I'm not sure how
you guys feel with the whole idea of
people discussing you know their their
financial desires on youtube or anything
but my goal is to really just do this
for a living you know my goal is to
really kind of move beyond where i am
now and to bring you guys videos like
this for a living because i can't really
imagine a better scenario than that and
i really think that's kind of the the
purpose of people's lives you know i
think that oftentimes people kind of get
stuck in a rut you know i think that
people have this tendency to believe
that their life is defined by graduating
from high school and then going to
college and then graduating from college
and then having kids getting a job
buying a house buying a car and then
retiring and i don't want my life to be
this regimented standard I don't want my
life to be this kind of thing that that
everybody has always done since the
1950s or even the beginning of humanity
you know I want to stand out I want to
be I want to do something different you
know and I want to be something
different you know I want people to
think of Marvel Comics and to think of
my channel I want people to think of you
know where's a good place to go to learn
about stuff and they think of my youtube
channel more so than that you know I
want people to kind of view me as you
know a teacher you know as a person
that's just kind of passing on knowledge
for those who are interested in getting
it you know and I recognize that not
everybody's going to like my videos I
recognize that I'm by no means the king
of YouTube you know and I'm by no means
the greatest person to ever explain
marvel comics in the history of humanity
I mean I know there are people out there
much much better than I am at this kind
of thing there are people who know more
intricate details of these characters my
goal here is to really be the best that
I can be in doing this it was to really
kind of bring the best quality videos
that i can think of bringing to you guys
you know and if i can be given the
opportunity you know if you guys can
grant me the opportunity to really kind
of do this full time I can't imagine a
better job I can't imagine a better
position that I would be in to be happy
you know because I think that's the
ultimate goal of people i think the
ultimate goal of people is to be happy
and I think people find that in a
multitude of different ways there are
people who amassed so much money and
they're never happy there are people who
are living in total poverty in there in
there in every hat never happy and there
are people who are the exact opposite
there are people that have a wife and
three kids and their struggle in every
single day and they're as happy as it
could ever be just because they have
what they want they have a phone there
are people that have an exorbitant
amount of money and they're as happy as
I'll ever be because there's nothing
they can buy I mean there's there's all
different kinds of people in this world
and for me you know happiness is defined
by spinning my life doing what I love
your happiness for me is being in a
scenario where I'm contain being in a
job where I am content and being
surrounded by fans and subscribers that
helped me to feel content because I got
to tell you guys y'all are fantastic I
don't know how many channels you guys
are subscribed to I don't know me only
one I don't know if you got to subscribe
to everybody from PewDiePie all the way
down to somebody who just started the
channel a week ago and they've got you
know 15 subscribers I don't know what
you guys are at in the scheme of your
subscription based on YouTube but you
know if if no one else has ever said
that you as a subscriber or a great
person then let me be the first one to
say it because I don't know you know
I don't know if I would be as happy as I
am doing what I am now if it wasn't for
you guys that doesn't mean that these
videos don't make me happy what it means
is that it's one thing to be in a room
an empty room talking about something
you love it's another thing to be in a
crowded room talking about something you
love and having people talk back there's
a whole different it's a totally
different dynamic to me it's a totally
different kind of concept you know for
me to talk about Marvel Comics is is
amazing and I love it you know but to be
talking about Marvel Comics and then to
hear you guys chime in and say Robin was
an amazing video where to hear you guys
try matt and say actually there was a
part of the video that you were wrong
about this is actually the correct thing
is equally as amazing because you know I
whole heartedly admit then I don't know
every intricate detail ever about every
Marvel comic book character ever your
self ominous it's just human nature and
in truth you know when I'm going over 50
years where the comics in a 20 minute
video I'm gonna miss stuff I'm gonna
have to skip over stuff just because if
I were to do a video about Iron Man for
example which i will and i were to talk
about Tony Stark because neo since his
first introduction in 1963 I think
whatever was tales of suspense number 63
like every word which one it is but and
i were to talk about him all the way to
the current day there were so many
things that tony stark got involved in
he started the illuminati you get to go
all the way back to the day when he was
wearing it is a great armor we could
talk about Tony Stark during the whole
age of Ultron wings in the future and
he's half human half cyborg you know we
could talk about all these different
versions of Tony Stark una and and it'd
be difficult to cover the entire life
span the entire life cycle of Tony Stark
and Marvel Comics over the course of 20
minutes but the fact that you guys will
chime in what do you do it because you
know you're trolling but whether you do
it because you know you genuinely want
to make sure that I'm putting the right
stuff up is it relevant to me the fact
is is that you guys are getting on here
and you guys are giving me your opinions
you guys are giving me your ideas to
know what you guys are saying thank you
this is a great video you know now I'm
getting caught back up on comics because
I haven't read them for 30 years or
because you're getting in a comic for
the first time and you're saying you
know this is great to me because now I'm
fine
getting things figured out you know
regardless of what your intentions are
you know it feels great to be able to
have a youtube channel and to be part of
a community where people are so excited
for the content that I upload that are
so excited for upcoming films and you
know podcasts and I'm putting out and
things like that you know it's just it's
a great feeling it's a really amazing
feeling and in truth as long as things
keep going this way I see no reason to
stop I can't I can't see a scenario in
which I wouldn't do this and which I
wouldn't be making these kinds of videos
you know and in the future I'm sure will
make you know great quality videos
they'll get better than they are now you
know I'm sure that there's always
something that can be done to make these
videos better and and some of the best
ideas that I've had have come from you
guys I mean the idea of having movie
coming but parents came from a buddy of
mine that was never really my original
idea I presented two versions of the
Apocalypse video soon the first version
had a I got a bird the first one had a
still picture of apocalypse and the
second one had like the moving color
book panels and I presented both
versions to him and I said which one you
know do you think is is better because
my initial concern when I created these
videos that have moving comic book
panels and stuff like that was that
people were going to say that's just
it's too much happening too fast you
know I don't care about the comic book
panels I just want to know the
information you know but he was like man
the one with the panel's is much better
because it gives me something to look at
it gives me something to see and I can
see the characters in the comics when
you're talking about them and I really
think that kind of goes back to the idea
of people who really kind of long for
seeing the characters in the original
comics but um you know I was like okay
so i uploaded that and sure enough you
know you guys came along and you guys
are like this is amazing these videos
are awesome but um but yeah you know
it's just it's you know regardless of
what happens you know regardless of what
things go on it's good to know that with
a subscriber base like you guys I
couldn't ask for more I really couldn't
I really couldn't think of better
subscribers then then you guys you know
because I think a lot of people are just
kind of arbitrarily subscribed to you
two channels they watch a single video
and leave but you guys
the most part seemed to be very
interested in the counselor that I'm
putting up and you guys seemed to be
very much a part of my youtube channel
and for that you know I think that you
guys are fantastic so again if you guys
are subscribe YouTube channels and the
people you subscribe to you don't tell
you how awesome you are subscribers then
again let me be the first to say that
you're awesome you you are amazing and
keep doing what you're doing you will
never once you know ever see me again on
to my youtube channel and say okay look
you guys are driving me nuts I don't
want to you know just stop replying to
stuff you got me nuts ridiculous you
know you guys will never hear me say
you'll never see me again in the
comments section and be abusive you know
and and to talk down to you you know or
two to insult you or anything like that
you know because you know I don't really
understand that I'm understand people
who get onto the YouTube channels and
and belittle their subscribers you know
and hear them down and tell them how
awful they are you know it's it's just I
don't get that I don't understand why a
person would want to do that but
nonetheless we've been ranting on for 4
20 minutes I can promise you feed your
videos will not last this long they
won't go on for 20 minutes they won't be
nearly as as lengthy as this but um but
yeah I'm going to go ahead and round
this video out and go ahead and bring it
to an end I just want to say that that I
appreciate everything you guys have done
so far and and honestly I couldn't ask
for a better subscriber base and than
what I have right now and in the future
of this channel after we're going to
make some amazing videos I think we're
gonna make some great content so that
being said yeah my neighbor's home I
think so my neighbor is hot like she is
so hot I don't know if she can hear me
right now but she's really hot like
she's she's blond man yeah she's pretty
good looking she's like jenna Marbles
kind of hot but anyway um yeah so I'm
gonna bounce off here and I'll catch you
guys later peace